You think a raped woman
She should be forced to have a baby.
How the hell to be forced
to be forced to have an abortion
because I do not understand
well in this sense
If the premise were to be removed
that allows you to have an abortion after raping yy woman
She would be forced
I was in California.
I talked to such a non-Christian
and he says so
and if someone glued a child to your back
Such two months
and this glue works
without killing the child
You will not get rid of this child in 7 months.
You have the right to kill that child.
What are you comparing now?
No,
I'm asking you for
You compare a raped woman
and a tragic story
to some story about some child gluing
I don't understand no I don't understand
I don't understand
It's the baby in the womb that's a week old.
2 months some
The truth has the same rights as this child.
which is taken out at 0
A woman who has been raped has the right to an abortion.
I even answer you sir
but I'm talking about gluing the baby to the bread
Well,
it's the same exactly.
if someone introduces me to the rape of a woman
it is from something
If someone forced me
will stick such a two-month-old fetus to the back
And he'll say you ain't got yy for a penny yy
There is no empathy for these rapes.
We have no empathy
guided by cold logic empathy How After the heart can
Empathy must be left to politics.
Empathy must be left at home.
I think there are more important reasons
For example,
if doctors are convinced
No,
a normal person will not be born.
because
yy protection of human life applies to normal people
If the fetus does not give a chance
A normal person will be born.
This is where it should be relaxed.
relaxed law
by Janusz Korwin-Mikke
Member of confederation
who will again run confederation
A potential coalition partner
Law and Justice
The United Right,
for example,
There were no votes
Everyone has the right to life
That's a fact,
but we can't demand it from women.
so that women
yy were heroines and yy and gave birth to yy truth
at the moment when
is this or are these rape fetuses
if there is a severe lethal defect
Besides,
one should clearly say
that our country does not help in education
People with disabilities and
As long as you don't take care of it
so long we should not demand heroism from women